humanity is an experiment of evolution
that might not work like we
we might not be able to do this and
that's
in my mind fine right okay
like we experiment may come to an end
or we'll just invent some ai to be the
next evolution of what we were
meant to be yeah i just i love humanity
i'm so glad we're here i'm so
i think it's very cool to be alive but
also
i was not alive for a few billion years
before i was and i didn't seem to mind
so
if we go away and this is a failure it's
just like i
really hope we don't but um but there's
just
when you mix things when you throw
things into the mix
like humans are
the human brain is pretty wired to like
sway
conservative or progressive just the way
that it is i mean you look at almost
every family and
within a same cluster of children who
grew up in the same house with the same
parents they can be politically
divergent and oftentimes there's
one or more that are and you're like
they're eating the same food they're in
the same place how does this happen
and it's just because we've evolved to
do that
one is like scarcity and one is
curiosity and one is openness to
experience and one is like preserving
what
the gains that we've made in the past
and these all have varying benefits i
mean
you think about the the american
ethos of individualism
and liberty is something that we are so
proud of
but it made us incredibly bad at
responding to a pandemic
right whereas china which
squashes descent and
potentially commits genocide on ethnic
minorities
is completely homogeneous in their
messaging and whatever and they
lock that [ __ ] up right and so if this
pathogen was actually worse let's say
let's say it was more like aids where it
actually lays dormant in you for six
months
or something and then kills
30 of the population or if it like aids
was
100 every american would be dead
because if there was that incubation
period no one would believe it's real
and like dr fouch would be like we can
detect it we know it's real and they'll
be like it wouldn't matter ain't nobody
dead this is fake
they're trying to control us yeah and
it's just like and so you see how this
experiment of humanity you put moral
judgments on the way
people behave which i think you should
it's like the pursuit of thriving but
there are different ways of existing and
in the experiment of we don't know what
the future holds
the fact that everyone does things a
little differently and cultures are
expressions of like
that sometimes one culture works better
than another one
at responding to a specific problem yeah
yeah the individualism
that is you know part and parcel of our
dna as americans
is is is certainly aspirational this
idea that we can all
you know kind of create our lives in the
in the vision that we would like
in a perfect world but it's it's also
you know it's shrouded in this
patriotism right but that patriotism
doesn't mean anything if we can't cohere
as a nation when we're faced with a
crisis so we're seeing this
fracture and i think you know to speak
to
the solution as long as the
um the uh
the wealth gap continues to increase
it's it it seems hopeless in my mind
like the more
the haves get and the less that the
have-nots
are are you know have access to it's
only going to ratchet this whole thing
up
and that doesn't bother me that's the
french revolution yeah exactly it will
end in
it will end in some kind of similar
cataclysm
and maybe we need that i mean that's the
like
yeah brutality of human history you look
at
it's just blood baths i'm curious if
there's certain aspects to our political
culture that are encouraging to me
obviously
a capital insurrection is not
encouraging
but a super divided government
is interesting to me in terms of like
the evolution of society because
if 50 like our senate is 50 50 right
right and that's like if you are
debating over
really complex problems that
literally one out of every two people
can disagree on
then the problem is then you're probably
living in a pretty advanced society if
we can live in the same world and two
people in the same room can believe
opposite about something if it was if
that if the room was
literally on fire and your skin is
burning
you're not going to argue over the fire
department they're coming that's a very
clear
that is such a cause and effect problem
with no gray area
but if you're talking about what makes
the economy work what rises
people out of poverty is it this or is
it that what is actually going to
change climate the climate crisis if
there is one or is this just the natural
you know like those things are so
complex and they're very serious
and may cause the downfall of our
society but in terms of
it's pretty remarkable that you can have
like the leaders of the country divided
down the middle yeah that just means
that society is now so complex
that we we solved a lot of the most
obvious problems
but that complexity leads to a certain
paralysis
when totally when government is divided
to that extent
but then if is paralysis
if okay if if if it is divided to that
extent
hopefully in a democracy even though
ours is a little screwy
it doesn't necessarily represent that
half the country believes this but
but a large amount of them believe one
way and a
larger amount believe another
but if if it was less divided and yet
there were that same division of beliefs
in the country and they just like
forced the other half of the country to
be doing something they didn't want to
do
that would lead to i think more
insurrections
and more well i think that's a function
of the
the the caliber and quality of those
beliefs are those beliefs deeply held
values or are they surface level beliefs
about
you know things more trivial and when
you get into
a real differentiation of value systems
i think that's where it becomes
you know very difficult to reproach
[Music]
you